hey guys my name is Jess it is monday
the twenty-eighth of mutt and here's the
game and stuff you want to know about
today sony has told Japanese newspaper
Nikkei that PlayStation VR could one day
run on PC when asked about additional
applications of PSP our PlayStation
executive vice president marcia su ito
explained since playstation 4 shares a
lot of its internals with pcs and the
possibility is there however you too
stressed that the focus of PSP are right
now is on games even though Sony may
eventually look to expand into other
markets oculus has also been vocal about
the potential of BR in expanded markets
and also happens to be officially
shipping their first consumer model
starting today so have you back to the
Kickstarter campaign in 2012 that you
can expect your rig to be on the way
through more news has come out of that
watch dogs to specifically that it's PC
version is going to be highly optimized
to work with AMD GPUs the original
watchdogs made use of nvidia gameworks
which has been a sticking point for AMD
in the past the company previously told
forbes gameworks represents a clear and
present threat to gamers by deliberately
crippling performance on AMD products
forty percent of the market divided in
the margin in favor of nvidia products a
claim which nvidia later denied AMD's
Roy Taylor tweeted that watch dogs too
will also feature Direct X 12 support
for Windows 10 users finally yet another
report has surfaced suggesting the Sony
are working on a more powerful
PlayStation 4 The Wall Street Journal
has now backed up the previous reports
from kotaku and Eurogamer which suggests
Sony is working on a new version of the
ps4 which can handle quote player and
gaming experiences including better
capacity for virtual reality The Wall
Street Journal explains that the new
version will allegedly feature enhanced
graphics and power being able to handle
quote ultra high-definition resolution
graphics which may suggest 4k display
outputs they added that it would live
alongside the existing ps4 with the same
software catalog reportedly the new ps4
will be announced before the October
launch of PSP are their pricing details
were revealed sony aren't alone in
looking at an upgrade though as Xbox
bosqueville faux fur has previously
teased quote a new hardware capability
for a hot one let me no doubt in that
comment section what you cared about
today and if you pick up a more powerful
ps4 you can add a game spot or we've got
stories on new Xbox one backwards
compatible games and a new division
exploit that is everything I happy today
but we should have heart by same time
tomorrow for a bunch more news I will
see them